today huh what the Downton thing for one
week we tried the tushie of a day that
you can install on most any toilet but
days are used around the world but are
not very common in America a bidet uses
water to clean your genitals and but
reducing or eliminating the need for
toilet paper
many claim it's a cleaner greener way to
go it's basically a device that works
water at your butt I know they exist
I didn't really have an interest in
using one touchy touchy cool all right
you gotta connect some things to the
water that seems reasonable enough I
haven't really been known to be good at
installing things but freedom to G helps
prevent UTIs hemorrhoids skid marks and
dingleberry who's got a problem what
this now a towel why can I can I just
wipe my butt with a toilet paper
this is not something people do right I
don't want to have a butt towel I'm
gonna try it well I'm really excited
about this aside from this I will air
dry we're trying to install the tissue
we never got a wrench
we're gonna make do we don't need a
wrench at all day two of the ten minutes
up start on step one shall we know which
way is off
[Music]
Oh God through the water pressures too
high I feel bad for everyone that
doesn't have a hand in their life we
were able to get a wrench from a
neighbor and I'm going to give it a
whirl see how the home installed
compared to the brush but definitely
powerful and cold but I'm into it let's
see how this week's goes
[Music]
I could not use it without laughing it's
so funny there's a bit of a learning
curve to the position okay I think I
figured it out I don't like it still I
mean I don't hate it it's fun I you know
it's like it I wake up in the morning
and nothing like having a spray of
ice-cold water up my butt I was able to
suspend this like reality for a little
bit being like it's not toilet water
that's shooting at my butt hole but it
is her she is we have a weird look at it
the weird relationship right now to be
honest and I am I just don't know if I
want to continue it this is what I've
always wanted in my life it's like I
feel luxurious I am happy that I have a
bidet in my home now just you know for
those spicy days you know sometimes you
eat like a Chipotle burrito and you
asked her like hot salsa and then later
you regret it
yeah I was really I was really into it
until I tried it and then I was like
this doesn't feel great and I was like
but it's practical now I'm like I can
live without it
pretty life-changing pretty great
[Music]
question do you do this when you pee
answer in the comments below
[Music]